foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
oh I'm super pissed this morning
and you might be mad at me
ah if you're not now you might be here
in a little bit I'm gonna get several
comments
I can already feel it because I don't
give one [__] I'm out of [__] to give
thanks especially this morning I'm out
of books to give you see my TV's all
[__] up number one I don't know I
think it's going out yesterday we had
some trouble it looked like it was
blurry like my camera's blurry but I
think it was just the TV was acting up
oh boy so it feels like the color is
going out on it so I'm dealing with that
this morning but you know I didn't have
no time to change that it just happened
this morning when I turned it on maybe
if you got good ideas on how I can
readjust it maybe that'll be good but I
doubt it
but it's not just the TV behind me that
is pissing me off it is absolutely the
[__] swamp monsters at the orders of
trump
that have acquitted Ken Paxton now I
will be quite honest with you I didn't
follow the trial step by step by step
but I do know the facts
the fact is is that Ken Paxton is under
federal investigation he's been charged
with felonies and Security fraud at the
state level and this guy is the we're
gonna return to be the Attorney General
the state of Texas
after his top AIDS this isn't like this
isn't like someone saw him somewhere and
witnessed him doing this is his top age
who knew he was doing this [__] said hey
we can't have this guy's attorney
general I work for him I'm supposed to
be in support of him and he should not
be the Attorney General
what happened was and you can damn well
better bet this is the [__] truth and
if you don't know it then you got your
head straight up your ass is that Trump
had everything to do with Ken Paxton
being acquitted
everything and and if you go look at all
the people who supported Ken Paxton that
weren't in the state of Texas like
Marjorie Taylor green
if you're not paying attention to why
Ken Paxton is acquitted it is because
they need the narrative
that Republican corruption is good and
it's okay no problem when you have
Republicans that are corrupt they're
post they're supposed to be the swamp
monsters
this is what got has got me a little
pissed off this morning and the reason
why is because the media is really
fumbling the ball here
they're fumbling the ball just like
they're fumbling the ball over there
Meet the Press with the interview with
Grandpa Poopypants I'll get into that
you're not gonna like me I'm I'm serious
you're probably not gonna like me today
um because I'm gonna do a lot of
speaking out where the audience really
doesn't like it just like months ago I
did with tyt and took them down a peg or
two and people kept commenting and
commenting Tony stop attacking the left
listen when they're when they're hurting
democracy I will attack them I don't
give a [__] who they are I don't give a
[__] I don't care it is not something
that we're gonna do here that someone is
Untouchable because the side that
they're on you were either on the side
of democracy in the institution of
democracy are you or not
that's that's just how it's gonna be
here at the Tony Michaels podcast and I
understand it makes some people mad a
lot of people I
I posted a screenshot of David packman's
uh Instagram
uh people got really mad at me they're
like oh you're really you're you know
you're being I think uh immature was
another one childish was another one
um but David packman is bad at this
just like Kristen Welker is bad at this
so be mad at me be mad at me be angry
that's what you should be you should be
[__] pissed that this [__] is
happening in our country
that Kristen Welker is gonna do an
interview with a guy who tried to
overthrow our government
he tried to obstruct official proceeding
and get Mike Pence to commit to reason
and his name and you're gonna refer to
him as Mr President get the [__] out of
here with this nonsense
[__] him
and if you don't see if you don't see
the normalization of criminality in this
country with these Republican Nazis then
you're not looking clearly
and just because it's someone on the
left not doing their job as a
commentator I don't give a [__] if
they're on the left or not
I'm gonna hold them to account if
they're not standing for Democratic
institutions in our [__] country
period
I don't give a good God damn who they
are
are what are why they're saying what
they're saying to keep their syndicated
contracts on their FM and AM radio
stations nor am I concerned what kind of
contract they have as a contributor with
MSNBC I will speak out against them
it's going to happen
and it will continue to happen
because we cannot we cannot capitulate
to these [__] fascists
if we allow them to normalize their
criminality they will normalize their
genocide bet
[__] bet
Jesus Christ Rhonda santis I don't know
if you know this Ron DeSantis is talking
about killing people with no due process
of law at the border he wants to execute
people with a bullet at the border no
due process of law
they're one step closer [__] there's
there's got there's a guy running a
state senator in my state of Missouri
running for governor and another [__]
idiot running for state senator and
they're using they're used they're using
flamethrowers to burn piles of books
come on man
we have to we have to be focused here we
cannot be calling [__] Donald Trump
Mr President in mainstream interviews
and Kristen Welker did a horrible job
a horrible job
while he just puked up lie after lie
after lie after lie continued
to puke it up
so am am I am I gonna am I gonna just
well Christian Welker she's on MSNBC and
MSNBC isn't isn't Fox News so you can't
[__] that I will attack her
and I will attack their narrative and I
will attack what they're doing to our
country
the mainstream media is not an enemy
right
they're not an enemy
but they're they're horrible at their
job and I think more than anything
they don't quite understand
their job anymore
they don't quite understand it their job
is to make profits for NBC Universal
that's that's their thought and that's
not really their job as a journalist
when you think about it in our
democracy's terms not not the industry
terms not the industry terms of the news
but in democracies terms of of you know
like the Constitution and the foundation
of us having a free press right
well that's the beauty of you
that is the beauty of you
is I I couldn't keep this mic on without
you
without you listening Without You
contributing engaging I could keep this
[__] microphone on
but I'm not beholden to someone telling
me what the [__] I gotta say or some or
some goddamn public companies profit
margin
no one's [__] doing that no one's
giving me money
you are the ones who support me in this
independent effort to yell and scream
and get [__] mad about what's
happening
and yeah again you know maybe just maybe
there are several people in the
mainstream media who do a really good
job because I believe there are
but I can't spend my time highlighting
and propping the people up that are
doing a good job I just sit back and let
them put their shoes on and do their job
and I point out to the you the ones that
aren't
and the reason why is because you have
to stay vigilant even against yourself
we capitulate to ourselves all the time
it's human nature it's it's a flaw that
we have
all humans have it
we're we're very biased especially to
our own
preconceived biases
it's a thing that happens
they take advantage of it they being the
mainstream media they take advantage of
it they're trying to make profit off
what your preconceived bias is
and you know
it's not
a secret
it's very obvious
that's why we don't have networks on
cable anymore that seem right down the
middle you know because that's not how
preconceived biases work in politics
most people who are right down the
middle don't pay attention to politics
they're worried about who's going to be
the starting pitcher today
who who's going to be the starting
quarterback of the Jets now that Aaron
Rodgers killed his Achilles I mean these
are the things that they might worry
about right
and it's easy for them to find those
spaces to talk about the stuff that
they're worried about and ignore the
things that I don't know provide them
the ability to watch
baseball on TV
to watch NFL football to be excited
about NFL football on Sundays and who's
going to be replacing Aaron Rodgers at
the Jets
folks this is our way of life and our
way of life is built on liberal
democracy
the entire thing all of it
and you might think I'm crazy but the
entire thing is built on top of us being
free
the whole thing
you think you think in an authoritarian
state that we're going to have we're
going to have the NFL as it is today
you think when we go to an authoritarian
if the project 2025 gets their way
and they give unilateral power to one
dictator one authoritarian like Trump
you think you think he's not going to
absolutely dismantle the the NFL the NBA
the MLB the way we know it he absolutely
will
you haven't studied authoritarian States
if you don't know that they're they're
the first thing they do is kill the
culture
that's the whole premise
why do you think why do you think
they're they're trying to restoke the
culture wars
sure they're trying to we already won
the culture wars we already won that
[__] America has [__] decided on that
nonsense that video games don't cause
people to be violent that's not the
reason why people are going and killing
little children in schools it's because
you don't do you don't do enough to keep
the [__] weapons of war out of
people's hands that's the reason why
it's really [__] simple oh and by the
way people people aren't sexual deviants
because of their political affiliation
that's not what it is it's not what it
is
it's not Lauren bobert and and it's
obvious
that your deviance isn't far-fetched
from yourself you [__] hypocrite
I mean the the worst thing about the
Lauren bobert thing and the reason why
she should resign is not that she was
groping up some dude in a theater folks
there's a million other [__] reasons
why Lauren bobert should not be in the
United States Congress and one of them
is not that she they were feeling each
other up in a dark crowded room I hate
to break it to you there's a thousand
other reasons before that one that she
should not be a congressperson okay
foreign
but again we're doing such a horrible
job at knocking these [__] down a peg
and we have to keep going
we have to keep going
uh Gary B on um on the live show chat on
Discord just said I'd love to see Trump
interviewed by Minnie Hassan yes many
Assan is one of them he gives no [__]
and if you watch many Assan when they're
lying he says stop nope stop it this is
my [__] show and you're [__] lion
can you imagine if they were to give the
Meet the Press seat to him holy actual
[__]
can you imagine him interviewing him for
the Meet the Press
wouldn't and here's the thing is Donald
Trump wouldn't actually get interviewed
by many it's on it wasn't he wouldn't do
it because he's he's a coward
he's a [__] coward
and here's here's what Meet the Press
and quits Chris and Michael went wrong
in this interview really honestly this
is where they went wrong they agreed to
certain questions in a certain Narrative
of the interview and they stuck to it
that's the problem
Trump is always deceitful
he's oh he's a [__] liar and he lies
to them all the time so why wouldn't
they deceive him to bring him in to get
him in the hot seat and ask the real
[__] questions the real [__]
questions
and hold his feet to the fire to the
truth
so much so that he might get up and
storm out and be like yeah we didn't
agree to this this wasn't what we agree
who gives a [__] if he leaves and he
cowers away and runs away from the truth
and from questions good
good but nope nope Meet the Press
Christian Welker one uh they want to
have an interview oh they want to have
an interview and they want to continue
the interview so we're going to stick to
the agreed the agreed questions and the
agreed and error [__] that [__]
get real get real with it
don't don't Pander to the [__]
especially Pander to his lies and let
him walk away just puking up lie after
lie after lie and then I'm really
disappointed to be quite honest this is
one of the most disappointing things
I've seen in this whole Christian Welker
Meet the Press I mean
I'm going to show you a couple Clips off
the Meet the Press thing where Andrew
and Mitchell is is playing both sides
she does the both sides they're
normalizing Trump as if somehow a
presidential candidate who tried to
overthrow our government when they were
the president somehow normal it's not
normal this is not normal [__] you
shouldn't be normalizing this garbage
but they are
here's the thing
here's the thing is that Jin Saki
someone who is really good in The Wine
House she was a great press secretary
she went after the media for a lot of
stuff that she's doing now
because she's got a contract
and she held Christian Walker in this
interview up like it was some kind of
accomplishment it was not an
accomplishment I'm sorry it wasn't it
was not an accomplishment for Kristen
Welker to sit there and let him [__]
just puke up why after lie after lie
after line when she knows it's a lie and
not challenge him on almost anything
and I know you're going to say well
there were some things that she kind
yeah but not enough
not enough
not enough if he didn't get up and walk
away and run away from her it wasn't
enough
we got to start getting real with this
[__]
because you see what happened in Texas
holy [__] are you kidding me
you don't know you don't know that the
criminal Republicans and Donald Trump
made sure Ken Paxton got acquitted so
they can say wow he got acquitted so why
can't I
I mean really and when you think about
it we're all criminals aren't we
what do you what do you think Ken Paxton
I want the reason why you think he was
acquitted
other than Republicans want criminality
in the Republican party to be normalized
because there's gonna be a lot of it
running around folks
I don't know if you've been paying
attention but there's a hell of a lot of
criminal indictments going on
in the name of Republicans remaining in
power have you noticed that
I mean there's there's thousands of
people
um being indicted and prosecuted and put
in prison I mean Jesus Christ there was
decades and decades just handed out a
couple weeks ago to The Oath Keepers in
the proud boys
Decades of prison
because they had tried to overthrow our
government as terrorists
terrorists they gave him a terrorist
enhancement
which you know in the long and short of
it is I'm looking forward to judge
chetkin because I know Jack Smith is
probably going to ask for a terrorist
enhancement on Trump
when that evidence is uncovered in trial
of what they actually did
and how they recruited the proud boys
and The Oath Keepers in their effort to
overturn the government because they did
they sought to recruit them as part of
their plan
if Mike Pence wouldn't do what they
wanted Mike Pence to do there's the
whole point
and all the Republican Senators and
Congress people know it
they know it that's why I don't give Liz
Cheney a pass because she knew it she
knew what Kevin McCarthy knew she was
the third in line after scalise she knew
the plan and it took her 190 days to get
to the floor and say Trump lost folks
we cannot get keep giving these people
passes
we have to stay vigilant and I don't
care I don't give a [__] if it's people
on the left continuing to give them a
pass I will call them out
and I will continue to do that I'm not
here to [__] you
I am not here to [__] capitulate to
someone who pays my to pays my rent
and pays to keep this mic on
I'm here to tell the [__] truth and I
know you're here to listen to it and
find it I understand that
now am I going to get super wealthy like
some of the ones that get big contracts
with MSNBC and other networks probably
not
probably not
but I'm not willing to sell that out to
be unauthentic to just shovel you full
of a bunch of horseshit because someone
wants to hear it
[__] that [__]
we have to stay on the foundation of our
democracy
and we have to fight it from that
liberal Foundation small L liberal
we have to
we cannot sell out
the moment we start selling out is the
moment they make Headway
and it's going to continue to seem like
they make Headway back into the
mainstream
they're trying their damnedest folks
fascism is knocking at our door they
have a [__] presidential candidate
who is a [__] two-term governor of
Florida talking about executing people
who are coming across the border with no
due process
because they're brown he wants to just
execute them they're when they're
Crossing an imaginary line they got a
[__] backpack on just kill them and
then ask questions later that's not how
our constitution works that's not how
the rule of law works that's not how any
of this works that's how it worked in
Nazi Germany folks
that's how it worked in Nazi Germany
that's how it works in the Middle East
and there's so many parallels to draw
the Nazi Germany and the Middle East
with their with their Theocratic fascism
that it's stunning
stunning
that the majority of Americans hasn't
woken up to this oh they're woke
that's what they mean by woke
people who realize that they're a bunch
of goddamn Nazis
and we can't let people get away with
[__] both sides and things are
capitulating that's why I went after
Mitt Romney last week Mitt Romney had a
really good opportunity to prove that he
was for democracy and he failed
he [__] failed with his words with
his message he both sides as if Biden is
just as bad as Trump
[__] that [__] I don't care what planet
you're on I don't care what your belief
system is if you believe in democracy
and you believe in the Constitution you
would vote for Joe Biden a million times
more than you would ever consider voting
for Donald Trump in these fascists
Mitt Romney stood there and said that
members of his party don't believe in
the Constitution
and he acts like Joe Biden's just as bad
what the [__] are you talking about man
it's not even close
I don't care if Mitt Romney doesn't
agree with Joe Biden on policy
I don't give a [__]
if Joe Biden didn't agree with Mitt
Romney on policy there's one thing that
they seem that they do agree on and
that's the Constitution but that's the
LIE
that's the LIE Mitt Romney is feeding
you is he doesn't really what he means
is is I believe in the Constitution for
me
for me for me for me I believe in the
Constitution for me
not for everyone else
especially not the people that Joe Biden
wants the Constitution for
I mean Jesus Christ Kristen Welker
was on MSNBC talking about how Donald
Trump may get the uaw's endorsement
think about it
the UAW is going on strike
the president the current president
United States is going to support them
and the former president is somehow
going to swoop in and lie
and shovel a bunch of [__] down of
America start to try to get the
endorsement of a union
when Republicans and Republican
politicians and Republican party for
years has done everything in their power
to destroy
destroy collective bargaining at every
measure and every state that they could
right to work right to work you [__]
[__]
get with the truth and if the truth
means that I got a post in David
Pacman's comments that he sucks at
commentary so be it if I gotta stand on
this show and continue to talk about the
left
then I'll do it I don't give a [__] if
it's tyt CNN or MSNBC and I don't care
what personality it is either I don't
give a [__]
when I see it I'll say it because let me
tell you something that's just as
dangerous or more dangerous than fascism
is for us to close our eyes and act like
that it doesn't exist and capitulate and
normalize the Republican Nazis
criminality
that's dangerous as [__]
I believe that MSNBC should interview
Donald Trump I believe that CNN should
everybody is anybody should be
interviewing Donald Trump and hold his
feet to the fire so much so that that
little [__] gets up and walks off
because he's too much of a coward to
answer a real [__] question and tell
the truth
and when that happens maybe America will
see him for he really is a [__]
fascist fraud
until then until then we have to stay
vigilant and we have to keep at these
[__] and holding their feet to
the fire the reason why Chuck Todd
left it Meet the Press anyways is
because Chuck Todd is a [__] hack
is a goddamn both sides in heck
when there is no both sides to democracy
folks there's not both sides Mitt Romney
there's not both sides Chuck Todd
there's not both sides Kristen Welker
there's not both sides to democracy
either you [__] believe in it or you
[__] don't
one or the other that's it
period
and if you're not willing to defend that
idea [__] you
I'm gonna defend it no [__] way am I
not going to defend it
every single day I don't I don't give a
[__] who gets mad at me I don't care how
many comments come after me
I don't care I'm gonna tell you the real
raw [__] truth of it and I'm gonna
give it to you to the lenses of the way
that you should be looking at this [__]
in your democracy
we are the ones who are going to save it
we are the ones who are going to keep
this democracy going it is us we the
people are the government and it is our
nation it is our country and we do not
have to let a bunch of [__] criminals
take it from us and make it a theocracy
and oligarchy
a fascist State we do not have to let
that happen
but if we don't speak out where we
should it's possible
so keep at it and keep with it one way
you can do it is subscribe here to the
Tony Michaels podcast I want to thank
all of you we passed 18 000.
um for for a while there we were really
stagnant with subscribers I think
YouTube You Know YouTube hates me guts I
hate my guts but we're starting to break
through them hating me
like I can't be ignored maybe so more
and more people are subscribing to the
Tony Michaels podcast I appreciate it so
much Gabe's had such great success with
his new show what was that line we've
got news today Dave's going to be on
today not Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
because he is having a special week
where he's taking some vacation so
you're gonna get to see Gabe's special
today
after the show on a Monday so stay tuned
right here on this channel
because you're gonna go right to Gabe
right after this show uh so stay tuned
for what was that line after the show
also
um I want to thank everyone who has
bought shots and who sent venmo chats in
um you guys are so great I can't show my
appreciation enough again I could not
keep this mic on without you guys
um it's it's it's it's it's important
um that that you guys engage in this
show but also the contributions that you
make uh to keep this microphone on like
I said so everyone no matter who you are
out there and I'm I'm trying to think of
a special way because there's so many of
you that have bought shots and if you
want to buy a shot
um you just go to the tonymichaels.com
you hit subscribe at the top you're not
going to want to miss a single thing I
send out notifications all the time and
you can buy a shot right here it's with
the PayPal account it's really easy just
click it you select which one you want
to do and you do that if you want a
different amount you can go down to the
tip jar or you can send me a vimo Super
Chat I'll bring it up on screen
um to do that also I I want to point out
some more links here while we're taking
care of some business here the Sunday
rant is here I'll make that public here
soon in the next few days it was patreon
only we talked about the library of
democracy last night that's right the
library of democracy or rebranding and
giving the Round Table democracy a total
[__] upgrade and you're not going to
believe the stuff that's coming out of
that upgrade it is fantastic it is great
news we talked about it on the Sunday
rant I will make it public so I'm going
to leave this link here so just watch
for That interview to go or that that
that Sunday rant to go public also
speaking of interview
you're not going to want to miss the
conversation that I had with Greg oliar
on his podcast Prevail that link is
right here you guys can go straight to
it a lot of people like that interview
so I was like you know what I'm just
going to put it on the website so you
can find it here's the venmo super chat
if you want to send me a message and get
it up on the screen is there also the
patreon page if you want to participate
in the Sunday rants
um and the the morning meeting we had a
morning meeting today on Mondays and
Fridays I do an hour before the show we
just sit and talk we had a great
conversation this morning uh it was
fantastic I I really appreciate everyone
who's joining in on those so go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels or hit the
link here on the Tony michaels.com when
you buy the 20 tier or more you
automatically if you use the same email
in the Discord
then you can you can actually get into
that room uh to on Mondays and Fridays
so don't forget to do that as well and
I've seen so many people upgrade on
patreon uh their their tier and also
join patreon so I want to thank you so
much from the bottom of my heart it
really means a lot to me I'm also I want
to mention this for the mods there's a
mod uh consideration sign up for them if
you want to be considered to be a mod
just go to the Johnny michaels.com click
this mod sign up form It'll ask you a
few questions and then you'll be on the
list for future consideration for
moderators which we're going to need
more and more as our shows expand and
expand and expand so I thank you so much
the audience and I thank you so much for
your support rather it be to engage what
you do here every single day you're one
of the most engaged audiences on the
internet that's no joke
we're a small audience but man we're
heavily engaged I mean right now there's
almost 2 000 comments in in my comment
box right now and I haven't even looked
at it which I'm gonna go do and you
don't go anywhere why look at a few of
these comments and we're gonna look at
some video so don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
break this is the best you guys stick
even through the fake brakes and the
charity breaks
you know maybe one day we'll have
corporate sponsors in there you know
like when we finally get rid of these
fascists in our government I have to I
don't have to yell and scream and say
the word Nazi all the time because there
isn't as many Nazis running around out
there in our government maybe one of
these days I'll be able to track a
corporate sponsor because the truth
won't be so goddamn ridiculous right
um so I thank you again I want you to do
something for me
um
I said the library democracy we talked
about this yesterday on the um the
Sunday rant but the library democracy
you know that's different right it used
to be the round table of democracy and
we're still gonna have the Roundtable
democracy it's just there's gonna be an
upgrade
an upgrade of the Roundtable democracy
to the library
of democracy and I want you to go follow
the YouTube channel and that's where
we're going to be posting the content
there's already a couple videos over
there already so I'm going to put that
in the chat right now so you guys should
go follow that YouTube channel for me
subscribe to that YouTube channel it's
going to be super important because
there's going to be a lot of work done
over there
um we've got a lot of a lot of new
things coming with the library democracy
that's why you haven't seen so many
round table videos here last few weeks
because we've been putting our effort
into planning the upgrade of the library
of democracy so not only we upgrading
the show and the [__] fam universe
but the library democracy is going to
get an upgrade as well and again I'm
going to make that Sunday rant public
um here in a couple here in a couple uh
here in a little bit oh is there a
sparkler array do we have uh do we have
sparklers from Hal Sparks show coming in
is that what's happening it feels like
that's what's happening is we have um
welcome to all the sparklers the
sparklers are always welcome to this
show
um Hal is uh who is Hal house Sparks uh
so thank you Hal for sending the um
sending the sparklers over here to the
Johnny Michaels podcast
um and uh so thank you to Hal for
sending that
spark charade the sparklers are here we
always appreciate the sparklers that's
another person that's not scared to tell
the [__] truth no matter what what
corporate dollars would would
say Hal Sparks he has a little different
way of doing and it shows a little
different than mine but hell's not Al's
not scared to
tell the truth on someone he he doesn't
like dyt either everybody's coming over
from the sparklers and I'm in good
company with them uh because
Hal does not care for self-defeatism I I
I I don't know for sure
um mine and Hell shows are on a lot at
the same time or they kind of overlap a
little bit and a lot of people don't
like that but I'm like look that's the
time he chose that's the time I chose me
and Hal have talked about it on the
phone before and we're like I'm not
gonna change my time he's not gonna
change his time
um so we're not competing now we're just
in the same universe and trying to do
the same work so if you get a chance and
you haven't listened to Hal Sparks go
listen to Hal catch some of his shows
catch some of his content
um and follow Hal everywhere so the
sparklers are always welcome here at the
Tony Michaels podcast
as always we have the
sparklers so thank you uh for that uh
what was I say oh library of democracy
speaking of that uh sparklers you're
going to want to get in on this too uh
sparklers are definitely going to want
to hear about this the library democracy
is the new upgrade of Roundtable
democracy we're still going to have
Round Table discussions so there'll
still be the round table of democracy
and we're going to do some of the short
tips and stuff but it's going to get
better and better and better so let me
let me do this one more time let me post
the new YouTube channel for the library
of democracy because that's one thing we
figured would be a great part of this
upgrade is giving its own space right it
needs its own space
to exist in
so grab um grab the link there in the
chat and go subscribe to the to the
library democracy's YouTube channel uh
we're gonna start piling up more and
more content what it is is just giving
you ways to engage quick easy fast ways
for you to engage and the other thing
too is if you know someone who wants to
engage but they're just unsure how to do
it it's so easy to share this content
with those folks
um we've already done several Round
Table of democracy videos about field
team six uh about uh fivecalls dot org
and also also we did one on ballotpedia
that was on the library democracy that's
the video over there now so go check it
out go check out the library of
democracy
and we will
um we will be getting more and more
content on that channel so I really
appreciate everyone who's went and
subscribed already and it's free to
subscribe over there at library
democracy just grab the link in the chat
and go hit subscribe on there um tyross
a great friend of mine Ty
you are you are you've been here for a
long time she's in a loyal Watcher of
the show every once in while she's in
the chat
um and she sent me a message here on
venmo and I think she didn't want me to
give her credit but I'm going to because
I love Ty so much she said podcast
podcast
so thank you for the support
um there in the venmo chat if you guys
want to get a message on the screen just
go to thetonymichaels.com hit the venmo
Super Chat and you guys will be able to
um to give it let me put that link in
the
in the Chan here as well so that way you
guys can find it really easy
and so thank you for your support as
always Ty
uh we love having you here I know the
audience loves your work and the work
that you've done so
thank you very much it means so much to
me and again it means a lot that you
guys support me not just again
monetarily if you can do that that's
great it keeps me going keeps the
microphone on but also the engagement
that is super important is the
engagement that we have and really
honestly if you want to get in on some
of the best engagement there is go to
the Discord they're chatting in the
Discord right now
and they chat live every single day
in that Discord and it's they never stop
either so it's not just during the live
show and there's so many resources in
the Discord
um that are there if you want to have
the best memes we've got a whole pile of
memes that you can find over there whole
pile of memes
just uh just go check out the Discord
click on the link and then verify when
you go in just go to the welcome center
it's really easy
to click on the little check mark box in
the Welcome Center to get verified if
you have questions you can get to the
Welcome Center and see that
[Music]
um
Stargell says they chat on Discord are
you live and Discord as well Tony you
goddamn right we are yes the show does
stream live every single day in the
Discord there is a stage set up where
they stream it live in there and they
have a live chat going on there's a live
show chat room that I watched during the
show so I can see the shenanigans going
on over there
and let me tell you something
um if you want a group of like-minded
people who are anti-fascist that's the
Discord to be in
I'm not [__] you they are vehemently
against the Republican Nazis in this
country so the like-minded but also
they need Jesus but in a good way in a
good way they need Jesus
not in a bad way they need Jesus like
Lauren bobert
they need Jesus in a good way so go
check out um the community because it is
a community that's being built over
there on the Discord it's like our own
little social media site
right it's our own little social media
Universe over there that the [__] fam
and and it is it is the Tony Michaels
podcast server but it's not all about me
it's about the community it's about you
guys connecting it's got you guys
talking to each other sharing resources
uh with each other sharing memes it's
all uh it's it's great fun over there so
check out the [__] fam over on the
Discord
it really is a great place to hang out
all right
it's enough uh
it's enough promotion for a minute a lot
of people are like oh man is this all
promotion I'm like well I gotta talk
about this stuff I gotta tell someone
what the hell's going on in places that
they don't know what's going on I got to
tell you the news
and there's news over there
let's see there's a lot of comments in
here about tyt you know and
and the comments aren't the way the
comments were when I first started
talking about dyd when I first started
like what are you talking about uh t-y-t
I love t-y-t
and I was like well you're not when I
get done with them you're gonna hate
them
they're gonna hate them you're gonna
hate them all right so let's go let's go
to some of the newsy news because we're
gonna get to the Ken Paxton [__] and
we're gonna get to the uh the Kristen
Welker interview and I'm going to show
you some of this stuff uh let's see
where shall I start where shall there's
so much there's so much
oh my God it's almost overwhelming to
even start on this but I want to show
you a meme
if I can find it pretty easy here I want
to show you a meme of Hunter Biden let's
start there because they're obsessed
with Hunter button oh my God they're so
obsessed oh
otter biting Hunter button
utter button but look here uh this is a
great meme it says Hunter Biden was
indicted for you
if Republicans can come after his guns
then they can come after yours see folks
this is the kind of narratives that is
going to beat back these [__]
[__] right because really honestly
their view on guns is not what you think
it is it's not oh it's unfringible and
if you infringe on anyone's right then
you infringe on my I mean unless it's
Hunter Biden and you know we can put the
people that I don't like in prison over
gun charges and infringing on someone's
second amendment rights because really
honestly we shouldn't be letting just
anyone and everyone have guns and if
someone lies to get a gun they probably
should be punished that should probably
be a thing I don't know if like a
20-year prison sentence because you
checked the wrong box on a form is
probably the proper punishment maybe
just having your guns taken away from me
you never being able to buy a gun again
that that could be a good punishment
maybe finding someone some money or
giving them a little bit of jail time
but 20 years really get the [__] out of
here that's all a bunch of nonsense
but when you look at it through their
interpretation of the Second Amendment
you know they're full of [__]
when the hunter Biden case comes up you
know they're [__] totally full of
[__] this two-way Bros should be out in
the [__] streets protesting that even
if if my enemy if my enemy can be
infringed on their second amendment
rights then they could do it to me but
they're not they're not mad they're not
mad because they don't actually believe
that [__] and I've been telling you this
for a long time that it's white gun
culture it's the guns it's the guns it's
the guns it's the guns but the fascists
love to keep the guns out in the open
and the profits out in the open and they
use white gun culture to delude these
[__] idiots out there that don't have
enough brain cells to rub together that
the reason why children are dying in
schools because we're not doing anything
about it
and that's what this is supposed to do
is get them to [__] think with what
brain cells they have left if they have
any left
is the [__] narratives that they
spin this one's pukes up
and maybe gets them to think a little
bit
Hunter Biden was indicted for you you
know this is all the nonsense that they
talking about with Trump if Republicans
come after his gun they come after yours
so what if it's all [__] if this
meme is [__] at least it gets him to
[__] think
okay that's that's what we have to do
we have to fight propaganda with
propaganda what do you how do you think
we're gonna win the war of information
do you think we're gonna win the war of
information just looking at their
information and going well you know I
guess I guess some people may feel that
way Mr President and and and you feel
like you believe that you feel like that
the election was stolen from you but and
and I guess you have the right to
believe that but uh shut the [__] up
Christian Walker shut the [__] up okay
he didn't have the right to believe that
he won the election and then act on it
he did not have the right
they don't have the right to go into a
[__] school and murder children just
because Greg Abbott lets them have the
guns doesn't mean they have the right to
do that
okay just because Donald Trump is a dumb
[__] and he believed that he won
and didn't lose doesn't give him the
right to try to overturn the government
just like Ken Paxton believes he's doing
the great work of his Hitler allies in
Texas doesn't give him the right to
[__] take State money and be a
corrupt criminal okay
it's the same [__] it's the same [__]
culture I'm a white man and I get to do
whatever the [__] I want when I want
because I'm a white man trust me I know
that's the culture I've [__] seen it
with my own two eyes when they think I'm
part of it and I don't want a goddamn
bit to do with it not a goddamn bit to
do with it it ain't gonna Advance our
country in any [__] way and ain't
gonna make our country better to
capitulate to that [__]
that somehow white men are oppressed and
white men are the only thing and the
only demographic that can make a country
better [__] you that's all a bunch of
horseshit that white men have been
telling each other stroking each other
off for [__] decades for centuries
really in this [__] country playing
that [__] game we don't have to do
that [__] no more we are past that
nonsense diversity equity and equality
is the only thing that will progress our
[__] democracy to be a better place
for our children and our grandchildren
one of these [__] days if it still
exists
if we don't [__] kill ourselves with
climate change or fascism in the
meantime
so you know what I don't give a [__] if
I gotta pump out pro-democracy
propaganda I don't give a [__]
not gonna hurt my feelings when we win
the war of information because that's
the war we're in we're not in culture
wars we've done won those they're trying
to [__] convince us that we should
fight another culture War [__] that [__]
ain't gonna fight no culture War
so spread Pro democracy propaganda where
you can
oh [__] speaking of speaking of
propaganda
a lot of people have shown this
two State politicians in the state of
Missouri oh man
here's another here's another [__]
example of two entitled white men who
think they can do whatever the [__] they
want and get away with whatever the [__]
they want hey Nick hey Nick what what
skeletons are hiding in your [__]
closet buddy that you have to
overcompensate with a flamethrower are
you [__] me what a bunch of God damn
in-so [__] now one of these guys is
running for state center the other guy's
running for governor these people are
members of our government now Nick here
Nick here Nick Schroeder whatever the
[__] his name is well I don't know he's
from St Louis [__] this guy [__] this
guy
this guy stood on the capital lawn the
state capitol on
in Missouri
and was beating Bud Light cans with ball
bats okay I want to give you a little
context of why why this matters with the
Bud Light thing and why it is compared
to this [__] flamethrower thing
this is all to capitulate to their
little [__] in-cell audience okay it
ain't got nothing to do with state
government and ain't got nothing to do
with keeping jobs because if you really
liked Missouri jobs you wouldn't be
bashing Anheuser-Busch cans and telling
people to boycott a Missouri company
because you're a little too sensitive
about who's who's trans and who's gay
and who's not Nick is so [__]
confused that if he drinks a beer he
just might turn gay as if that's a bad
thing look Nick we know you're probably
in the closet we get it it's cool if
you're in the closet that's fine if
that's the way you want to live your
life and your lifestyle fine whatever I
don't care but really honestly man it
would be much better if you just came
out with the truth we would accept you
honestly
we as long as you're not [__] trying
to get rid of certain groups of people
and not being a [__] fascist if you
just were more authentic just come out
of the closet be authentic about it it's
okay it's okay you don't have to
self-hate [__] okay just like they
[__] do performative stuff he was
performing an act on the capital lawn
where they set laws and policies and
he's bashing cans of beer where in the
state of Missouri
there are tens of thousands of jobs that
are provided
by Anheuser-Busch Missouri jobs
part of the economy is kind of built on
some of those jobs bars restaurants
distributorships drivers people who work
in the Bud Light plant
on and on and on it goes
and Nick just shits all over that as a
United or as a as a Missouri rep doesn't
give a [__] doesn't care about
missourians doesn't care about Missouri
jobs doesn't care about the Missouri
economy all he cares about is him
bashing gay people
just like burning [__] books it's all
about being a Nazi for Nick that's all
it is is about being a Nazi for Nick
and Nick anything he can do to appear to
be the Nazis of the Nazis of the Nazis
that's what Nick's gonna do
even if it's filled with self-hate and
lies Nick's gonna do it and the reason
why is because of his audience folks
that's why I'm not that's why I can
rustle through the [__] is because
you guys don't come here for the
[__]
you come here for the real raw truth not
a bunch of [__] polls that are all
bunch of [__] rigged ass [__]
that say what the media wants them to
say
yeah come here for a bunch of data
because you really know the truth you
know that Americans don't like Trump and
don't like this nonsense that this
closeted [__] Nick is doing here I
listen
I've seen Nick in person I've seen him
in person
Nick I've seen you in person and dude
dude listen
you're you're not as manly as you think
you are
you're not as you're not as manly as you
think you are you're just not man you're
just not and you don't exude exude
masculinity either I know you're trying
to overcompensate and that's what this
flamethrower video is about is over
compensating and to really show their
Fascism and their hatred for people who
know that they're not manly because
they're not
um
but I'm going to show you the video here
but because it's kind of funny that they
think this is cool right and a
flamethrower is kind of cool I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna disagree with that
flamethrower is kind of cool I mean we
actually let me tell you something in
the Pacific in the second world war the
flamethrower really kind of want us that
that war with the Japanese that was a
long fought war in the Pacific
and there was there was hundreds of
thousands of Americans that died and
these these flamethrowers they really
protected against fascism but they
weren't designed to for for the
Americans people
the setback here is that this is a
fascist symbol because what they're
doing
is they're [__] burning a pile of
books with these flamethrowers okay
most most people who want the imagery of
War want war on the enemy that's trying
to kill us not books that oh my God
people might read books oh my God can
you imagine if someone read a book
because Nick Nick I don't know if you
know the history of the flamethrower and
if you know the history of the book
the book is killed a hell of a lot less
people than a [__] flamethrower you
[__] [__] there's not too many
people that have died at the hands of
books
oh I I it doesn't matter
so here they are here they are
let me show it to you here here you go
[Music]
I want to show you something here
wait for it wait for it
[Applause]
yay
let's go Brandon
again
I don't know why these people love over
compensation right I don't know why they
love over compensation I don't know why
and again they're probably
overcompensating for a lot of things
size you know masculinity
um sexuality I would imagine that's why
Nick Nick hates hates the lgbtq I mean
hates them
oh man he [__] hates him claims he's
some kind of [__] Christian and [__]
but here's the thing these people Nick
is running for state senate and the guy
the other guy with the flamethrower is
running for governor of the state of
Missouri and they blame everything
that's wrong in the state of Missouri on
Democrats Democrats haven't held a super
majority or a majority for that matter
in Missouri in over 20 years almost 30.
so these people are blaming
the the mishaps of Missouri government
on
Joe Biden who's been in office for two
years and Barack Obama who has been out
of office for six years was in office
for eight
okay and they were in power in Missouri
while Barack Obama was the president
they had a super majority they could
basically do whatever they wanted hell
they overturned the Democratic governor
a lot of times his vetoes
[__] out of here man this nonsense this
narrative that Republicans
somehow aren't responsible for the [__]
that happens in these shitty red States
it's their fault
it's a hundred percent their fault
they've run these states with Subaru and
jordy's for years
they just don't know how to govern they
suck at it and the reason why is because
they don't care about their [__]
constituency
so much so that they're willing to run
off public schools
libraries hospitals and their rural
communities so that they can blame it on
Democrats Let me Give an example they'll
defund they'll defund libraries so the
libraries leave the rural communities
they'll they'll make sure to demonize
Obamacare
demonize Obamacare so that the rural
hospitals don't get their funding from
the federal government that they rely on
to stay open in these rural areas so
their constituents have a place to go
and they're [__] sick to receive
health care so there you go they don't
have libraries they're in [__]
hospitals which are like anchors of a
community right especially rural
communities because some of these rural
communities you got to go an hour and a
half or two hours to reach either one of
those things
and now they're trying to pass vouchers
because Christianity and Bible and God
In School type [__]
and they're going to take away Rural
Community Schools
with privatizing with Charter vouchers
in these in these states and you know
why they're doing it
let me give you a secret prophets and
blame
that's right
profits
and blame they want to reap the profits
and they want to say oh it's Joe Biden
let's go Brandon it's all his fault that
you don't have rural hospitals [__] out
of here because you thought you ain't
got libraries or public school it's the
Republicans in these states and by the
way they're welfare states these states
like Missouri Alabama Louisiana they're
[__] welfare Queens those are the
real welfare Queens not the [__]
racist Trope that white Christian
nationalists always want to give to the
black community the real welfare Queens
in this country are white Christian
nationalists that's the real welfare
queens and they run these states that's
why the states are welfare Queens
they take way more in federal dollars
than they ever get back because they
destroy these communities do you want to
know the reason why rural communities
suck
people in rural communities because you
keep voting for [__] boxes
and the problem is is that they
convinced these [__] people that
there's no other alternative
but republicanism Nazism right Christian
nationalism
if there would be someone in these
communities that would stand up and say
nope I'm [__] gonna run and I'm gonna
run on a ticket of people who believe in
government who want government to work
for their constituents
and they want these states to do what
they're supposed to do not [__] have
some stunt where they're burning burning
boxes of books with a flamethrower the
[__] out of here man
the [__] out of here
and you know what I really don't care if
those boxes got books in them or not I
don't care I don't give a [__] do you
think they give a [__] when they lie you
think Nick Nick gives a [__] when he
lies about the lgbtq committee to pass
legislation to exterminate them in our
state you think he gives a [__] he
doesn't give one [__] not one [__]
when he spreads his shitty ass German
[__] Nazi propaganda his 1930s
Germany Nazi propaganda that's what Nick
does that's what Nick does
see you know what you know what we
should do fire with fire get our
flamethas out of democracy burn these
[__] to the ground it's enough
of this nonsense it's enough of it
maybe we should have a show
maybe we should but that's that's the
point is we have to fight back we have
to get in the ring where where the
battle is
we can't we cannot win this and we
cannot get them to crawl back underneath
their rocks if we don't go head to head
with them
speaking of that not going head-to-head
with them let me pivot
to the [__] interview
and the great oh
look at the smile this isn't in the
interview folks but this is much worse
this is about the interview uh about the
interview
Christy Welker even she looks even she
looks like her soul has left her body
doesn't she
it looks like she really did sell her
soul you know the the song The Devil
Went Down to Georgia
she didn't fight the devil she's just
like here you can have it you can have a
video and you can have everything else
hell you can have the whole thing just
take it Neville look at her
a lot of people are gonna be mad at me
you can be mad at me and I'm gonna
attack him for this but I don't give a
[__] like I said I just don't I don't
care anymore I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna push fit around this
anymore if you're if you're doing things
to damage democracy I'm gonna call you
out on it I'm gonna do it I don't give a
[__]
um so let's listen to her talk to Andrea
Mitchell here about her great interview
she had with the Mr President Donald
Trump oh he's he's so he's such a good
criminal he'll make a great president
when he's the he's a criminal it'll be
great
new moderator at least the best first
time I can say that I know it and it's
surreal to hear that great to be with
you Andrew just off of this
extraordinary interview first of all
Extraordinary oh it's an extraordinary
interview listen to that Alex it's
extraordinary uh no you know what's
extraordinary you know it's
extraordinary and stunning that you
[__] idiots capitulate to his
criminal ways and his [__] lies it
listen to me when I tell you this listen
to me you should be [__] pissed
that Andrea Mitchell just said this
interview was extraordinary the only way
that it would be extraordinary is that
Kristen Welker dug into Donald Trump so
[__] hard that he got up like a
coward and ran off the set that's the
only way that it could be described as
extraordinary and it wasn't even [__]
close so she gets no credit none not
from me not one [__] shred and Andrea
Mitchell should be off the air for just
saying what she said extraordinary my
[__] ass
let's continue
what was your impression from that
exchange well I think that you heard
former president Trump who is fired up
about a lot of these issues and
obviously trying to draw sharp contrast
with the president by manufacturing oh
my [__] god oh my [__] God I I
don't even know if I have to give
commentary over top of this I know I
have to give commentary over top of this
really honestly I'm more pissed off
about this [__] conversation about
the [__] interview then the [__]
interview itself to be quite honest
because the entirety of the MSNBC
apparatus is like oh congratulations to
Kristen Welker on the extraordinary
interview with Mr President Trump get
the [__] out of here with this nonsense
he's a goddamn traitor he tried to
overthrow our [__] vote you
[__]
interview him in that context only
that's the only context that matters
is that why why is the Republican party
going to kill their party because they
can't [__] get rid of this Criminal
they can't figure out a way to walk away
from this criminality to this swamp
monster like Ken Paxton like the Texas
Republicans can't walk away from that
[__]
pull your [__] heads out of your ass
MSNBC and I I'm gonna call out every
[__] one of them I don't care who it
is who acts like this interview is great
Jin sake and the rest of them I don't
give a [__]
I'm not opposed to MSNBC interviewing
Trump frankly I encourage it I want the
[__] out there talking the more
he talks the worse it gets for him but
they should not they should not let him
[__] wholesale his lies
they have a [__] duty
not just to their [__] profits but to
this goddamn country and the people of
this country and our Constitution that
affords them to the right to freedom of
press they [__] have an oath as far
as I'm concerned
cannot we cannot let them get away with
this
that they're just gonna [__]
normalize this activity listen to the
normalization listen don't say one
[__] thing not one [__] thing
about how he's a goddamn criminal listen
manufacturing has gone up in recent
years we should say that
um but you heard him I thought it was
very notable oh notable the endorsement
oh my God Auto Workers oh my god oh well
[__] Stephen from the president of the
Union underscoring just how hard that's
going to be watch the devil's size watch
watch President Biden there it is there
it is oh my God in an interview with
Donald Trump she asked about the UAW but
she can't [__] help herself she just
can't [__] help herself but to say
there's no way Donald Trump's gonna get
the UAW and neither is neither is Biden
wink wink wink
what a terrible [__] decision MSNBC
has made and NBC is made to get rid of
someone we knew who was a [__] hack
and a capitulate or at least we knew it
and you're you know what people have
been really pissed off at me for
speaking out against MSNBC and some of
the personalities on there well how do
you feel now huh because the same
[__] the same [__]
I've been speaking out against would say
this interview was extraordinary just
like Andrew Mitchell did because they're
paid to say that [__]
don't get [__] mad at me because I
tell you the truth get mad at yourself
because you haven't realized it yet
get real with it
I know it's gonna hurt I know it's gonna
take a while and I know it's gonna be a
lot a lot a lot of a long slog to get to
a position where we need to be
but it is it is about damn time that we
tell these [__] what we think I
don't care who they are where they've
been what degree they have what position
they had I don't give a [__] if you're
full of [__] you're full of [__] [__]
that's why I went after Glenn uh some
people are still mad at me ah but Tony
but get get [__] out of here I don't
give a [__] he's full of [__] about the
14th he's full of [__]
[__]
that's someone someone just said on them
on Discord said we're in the Tony
Michaels cult yeah the cult of Truth
encourage you guys to be mad at me
honestly I want dissent
do you know what descent breeds
it it breeds to not have to listen to
[__] like this
if if Kristen Welker had a little bit of
dissent in her and she would have
dissented against Donald Trump and his
[__] lies I wouldn't have to be
sitting here talking about it
we would be watching clips of trump
making an absolute [__] fool of
himself
and be crying and whining and walking
off the set
so descent is good
that's why fascists [__] hate dissent
because descent ultimately leads to One
path
and usually one [__] conclusion
especially when your descent is against
[__] lies okay
so yeah honestly you might be in the
Tony Michaels gold I don't know
but if you're in the cult of Truth and
descent fine [__] that that's where you
should be anyways if that's the way you
want to look at it and I'm saying it's a
good thing because they're laughing
They're laughing over there of course
you know they're joking The Cult of
Truth like honestly folks I I don't go
delete comments
because you said something bad about me
in the comments on YouTube like I don't
go you go look at them [__] they say all
kinds of bad [__] about me say all kinds
of [__] about me dissent is good I want
you to question what I say it's
important it's important that you
question what I say
and anyone else that says anything you
should question them to
um Karma here says you know and I'm
really disappointed here
um but I understand I understand and
Karma says here on YouTube I am in the
cult of Sanchez the guy with the last
name Sanchez I'm I'm gonna be honest I
I'm growing to be a
an avid cult member myself of
Gabe Sanchez
oh man oh man oh man now let's let's
finish this up and there's gonna be more
yelling and screaming on the other side
of it I'm sure because
it's not going to get any better but
look taking a step back it speaks to the
importance of unions in this upcoming
election and of this state Andrea this
is the State Michigan of course that
former president Trump won in 2016 lost
oh my God it's always quite close and
he's clearly making a very strong play
for it as well and of course leaning
into his deal-making status which he
talks about of course a lot Jesus
[__] Christ not one mention she's
talking about the state of Michigan
think about this Kristen Walker's
supposed to be really [__] smart
she's supposed to be on top of it she's
the [__] Meet the Press host
she's talking about Michigan all how he
won in 2016 lost in 2020 and he's trying
to really work those you [__]
there is 16 [__] people who are
indicted on felonies for trying to
overthrow the vote in Michigan at his
Direction you [__]
you [__] you [__] that
is enough that is enough to turn off
Meet the Press forever and to never
listen to any commentary that Kristen
Welker ever says ever again
all her credibility
gone
and you thought I was gonna show you a
bunch of [__] videos of her
interviewing Trump nope because it
really honestly it ain't about the
interview with Trump I mean yeah she
should have done it totally differently
she's a [__] coward she's a [__]
coward but how they're out there selling
this [__] thing
you [__] they're not selling it
like this son of a [__] lied for a
whole hour like he sat in front of me
and he just don't lie after lie after
lie after lie after lie after lunch he
never stopped lying I tried to get him
to stop lying he wouldn't stop lying
nope they're like oh yeah Trump really
good if Michigan if if you supports him
it would be really important in his
election to overthrow the government of
the United States and turn it into a
goddamn theocracy
and get rid of democracy what a piece of
[__] Kristen Welker let me tell you
something Kristen
when the fascists take over this country
when they take over this country
there is no meat to press there is no
Kristen Welker there is no Free Press
there is no dissent
okay what how do you think democracies
are made but descent against the lies
huh
descend a little bit have a little bit
of descent okay challenge a [__]
challenge him
would be helpful to the rest of our
country
all right
I don't even know that I'm gonna have
time to show you the interview and do I
really even need to show you the
interview having them sell this the way
that they're selling it on their Network
as if this is the greatest interview of
all time is enough to tell you is enough
to tell you
about what the interview's about
honestly it is
that's enough for me
it's enough for me
to know what the interview's about
the way that they're selling it
okay uh speaking of interviews Rhonda
santis was on Fox News and they were
actually Fox News was tougher on Ron
DeSantis then Kristen Welker was
on Donald Trump but let's let's watch
this little clip here about the
impeachment I mean look uh we can sit
there and talk about the proper role the
impeachment but they open this on Trump
based on a phone call to Ukraine there's
way more evidence for this one and
they've got a lot of investigatory work
to do but I think they should pursue it
do you why why is he relegated to the uh
I don't know what hour the media Buzz
plays you know this show and I don't
know who this guy is but God damn
Ron I thought you could get like a like
a a leading show or something on like
Fox News Sunday but I guess you can't I
don't know I don't know what what day
this is on but really uh Fox News kind
of put him in a shitty spot hey he is in
the shitty spot and then and then they
were like yeah you're gonna come on and
you're gonna really
um you know prop Trump's campaign
I don't know if you notice what's
happening but Ronda Santos is really
floundering like I said he would
and he's gonna continue and his
political career is all but over I mean
if he wants to he can continue to be the
Florida fascist for a while
and he's gonna he's gonna get he's gonna
get the opportunity to to finish his
term is Gibb gibner governor of Florida
um but you know Ron desantis's political
career is over he's all but he's all but
going to be just on boards he'll
probably make he'll probably make a lot
of money being on corporate boards and
and think tank boards and all these
fascist groups that get together and try
to figure out how to make us a Nazi
State he'll go be on those boards he'll
get paid hundreds of thousands of
dollars to be on each board but his
political career is over so I guess we
have Donald Trump to thank for that but
we also maybe have Fox and he's a thing
for that because this is horrible this
is horrible and again they're rougher on
Rhonda santis than they are then Kristen
Welker was on Trump just saying you're
saying
now let's see what what are the pieces
and news do we have God damn we're
almost geez that's Christ
you see this we're we're almost at the
bottom of the second hour and [__] holy
moly I gotta do something real quick
um I gotta add I gotta add the show why
in the hell isn't that popping up where
is his
where is his
now Gabe Sanchez is probably gonna join
us in just a bit
um he'll be he'll be he's airing a show
and I don't see his link what the hell
boy oh boy oh boy here here here's a
link and he sent it to me see that hmm
what was that live is going to be right
after the show here uh so you'll be able
to
you'll be able to
um watch Gabe Sanchez what was that live
as soon as the show's over and I'm
setting that up right now save boom
there it is okay so now it's going to
transfer directly he didn't have it up
when I was making my show so she wanted
to get that out of the way let's see
here
oh there's a lot of questions in the
chat but you guys are yelling and
screaming about the media
um as you should as you should okay well
let me let me show you one clip here
this is from Christopher Webb
and this kind of spells out the entire
interview in just seven seconds and how
it went and how it's gonna go and how it
went over and why they're selling it is
a bunch of a big pile of [__] listen to
this let's see if you can catch it
president Trump welcome back to Meet the
Press thank you
there you go there president Trump
welcome back
thank you
does that spell it out for you
I mean I don't know how else to to give
it to you I don't know all right um so I
want to go to another [__] ridiculous
thing that's going around on the
internet
um right now these [__] [__] boxes
protecting [__] boxes and but here is um
you guys know this uh soliman
sell him on that got into the um he's
getting into the uh the rooms with Mario
I haven't been in a room with Mario in a
long time one of the reasons why is
because of this asshat he has him as a
co-host and you're going to understand
what I'm talking about when when I show
you this
um of course Mario says media hit pieces
eliminates threats Elon Tucker Brandon
Tates hey it's not hit pieces this
shit's real okay now in Solomon says
Andrew Tate Tucker Carlson Elon Musk and
now Russell Brand can conform or they
will take you out conform to what to not
[__] sexually molesting people to not
harassing people they're not sexually to
traffic people that's what yeah they
should conform to that you dumb
[__]
they should conform to not trafficking
people or sexually assaulting people or
raping people our joke about it our
support people who do that speaking of
shitty interviews Tucker Carlson has
done interviews with Elon Musk and
Andrew Tate
trying to normalize your criminal
Behavior including human trafficking
when they claim to be for the kids and
all that [__] the [__] out of here
here is my response you [__] dorks
always playing the victim always the
victim always no matter what no matter
what a lot of people got mad because I
quote tweeted this they're like oh
you're just giving silly amount of
platform listen it's my [__] Twitter
account and yes I called it Twitter Elon
it's my [__] Twitter account I get to
do whatever the whatever the [__] I want
with it and if it's to point out that
he's an [__] and give you the post
where he's an [__] so you can go tell
him he's an [__] that's what I'm
gonna do
that's what I'm gonna do
because I believe that the Tweet doesn't
say anything but that
it's all the same it's this they're the
same as Ken Paxton in [__] Texas
they're protecting sexual abusers sexual
assaulters human traffickers protect
each other these Republican criminals
protect each other
that's what a swamp is that's why it's
so [__] swampy that's why they're the
[__] swamp monsters
the [__] out of here with this nonsense
that I can't I can't oh you shouldn't
well you should you shouldn't the quotes
you're just giving him a platform you
know how platforms work it's my platform
it's mine
and I'm not like oh well yeah just
settle down sunny
rest the brand will have his day in
court no give me a break
you shouldn't be protecting these [__]
especially lumping them in with Carlson
Elon Musk and [__] Andrew Tate
[__] out of here
I'll go after him I don't give a [__]
don't care and you know what the
mainstream media is going to tell you
this [__] they're not going to tell you
this [__] they're not gonna do
they won't because they can't
today oh here's a here's a tweet I'd put
out about Ken Paxton because it really
felt like everyone was surprised I
wasn't surprised when they like Ken
Paxton was acquitted I'm like yeah that
sounds about right I I'm like yeah that
sounds very right I bet Donald Trump
made I don't know half dozen phone calls
and Bam he was acquitted I said why are
you all so surprised getting Paxton was
acquitted the Republican Nazi protected
Trump twice in the U.S Senate the second
time after he attempted to overthrow our
government
come on
come on it really it's surprising that
Republican criminals are going to
protect Republican criminals and do
anything in their power to make sure the
criminals are still in power you're
you're really surprised by this come on
man
this is not surprising or shouldn't be
shouldn't be
let's see what else we got oh by the way
the Russell Brand thing he's being
criminally charged or criminally accused
of a lot of [__] rape assault abuse
and it feels like the evidence is out
there that it's it's probably gonna be a
real thing
so good luck to him good luck to him
um you know what let's jump back to the
UAW shall we shall we jump back to the
UAW and I want to show you a couple
things here okay first off I want to
show you a video and I don't retweet a
lot of senators and I don't retweet a
lot of Congress people because I don't
feel like that's my Arena to retweet
them okay just give them a straight
endorsement of their video
but I did this one
and there's specific reasons why I
retweeted this video
[Music]
um
number one it's because it's the support
of the UAW
but here is John Federman which I think
is one of the most authentic Senators
that we've had in a long time
and there's not much anyone can do about
it because he's from Pennsylvania and
they know he's authentic and they like
that about him more than anything else
they like that John fetterman is
Pennsylvania that's what they like about
him and he is Pennsylvania in this video
and the reason why is because he's going
to support the UAW
and just watch
comes up with a hoodie on folks a thumbs
up with a hoodie on okay
now it doesn't seem like much but here
here is here's his tweet okay
he says hold that line UAW on my way to
join you now solidarity
okay so I'll do it now I've never been a
union member
I can I can tell you that I've never
been a union member I've never been a
member of the Union
nor has I have I ever been approached to
be a member of a union
never in my life
not that not that I'm a huge huge union
guy
but I know the importance of unions and
I know the history of unions and what
unions have done for our country okay
and what the unions have done for the
people of this country average working
Americans and they should continue that
work and John fetterman is is working in
solidarity I don't know if you guys
notice the uh the Drew Barrymore problem
that Drew Barrymore had
okay here's the story here's a bit of
the story before we go into the
fetterman hoodie Scandal oh hoodiegate
hoodie gate in the Senate oh they're
really upset about hoodiegate
the Drew Barrymore here's the skinny of
it I'm not gonna show her video Drew
Barrymore uh suspended her show because
of the writer strike she didn't have
very many writers or she had writers on
her show some of these shows
um
don't have writers like my show is just
me there's no I don't have like a team
of people writing this [__] that I'm
saying I'm just saying it so I don't
have any there's no writer stamp here
okay Drew Barrymore utilized writers for
her show they wrote the show
now she wanted to bring her show back
but she was going to bring it back
without writers
okay she was gonna scab kind of the The
Writer's Union because basically what
she was saying is is that you know what
I want my show back I want my show back
and I'm gonna bring it back without
writers even though the show was with
writers before which is a really shitty
thing to do
it's a really shitty thing to do it's
not solidarity at all when she posted
that video on the internet there was a
lot of pushback okay
so because there was pushback on the
internet she decided to go back on bring
her show back so she was gonna bring her
show back and then she's like no we're
not
which is a good thing now people like
Bill Maher and others are going to bring
their shoe back which you know if you
want to be a scab and you want to be
known as a scab great do that
more power to you now we just know who
you are
that's what it is we just know who you
are you're a scab
but here's the thing
is that everyone deserves to get their
fair share of the GDP in this country
and I say it that way specifically
because a lot of people a lot of people
on the left want to attack
um capitalism with unions and that's the
opposite of what unions are designed to
do unions are designed to keep
capitalism in check
because capitalism isn't always a bad
system especially especially
if the unions are in place
and the unions can negotiate with these
corporations and keep them in check okay
that's the point
that's the point and what the unions
typically are doing right now is exactly
what the corporations are scared of the
unions are going hey you top ass manager
[__] you CEOs and your top
Executives you're making all the money
you're taking all the GDP
you're taking all the [__] GDP and
it's us that make that GDP for you
and you know what we're gonna do we're
gonna take our share and if you don't
like it [__] you try to do it without us
because you won't do it without us
and that's the whole point
that's the whole point of collective
bargaining that's the entire point of
that part of capitalism
why do you think Republicans want to
destroy it unions they want to destroy
collective bargaining because it doesn't
help their [__] fat cat corporate
friends
and for any Union member out there to
vote for a republican it's a little
[__] ass backwards it's kind of like
the whole wow if they can do it the
Trump then they can do it to me yeah if
they can do it to you they should be
able to Trump you dumb son of a [__]
your thinking is backwards that's why
you're voting for Republicans as a union
member doesn't make any sense they want
us Crush unions because they don't want
collective bargaining because they don't
want the rich fat cat corporate friends
having to give you their portion of the
GDP
if you guys don't know what GDP it's
gross domestic product
it's the overall gross product that we
produce in this country
as us the people
you know one percent takes 99.9 of the
GDP they take it all
one percent takes the whole [__]
kitten caboodle we don't get [__]
and that's not the way it should be
that's why I stand with John fetterman
in solidarity I stand with the UAW I
stand with the writers Union sag I stood
with the UPS drivers we should stand in
solidarity with every single one of
these unions trying to get their share
of the GDP because it's enough of the
[__] it's enough of the [__]
uh someone says I should consider uh
joining sag I'm not saying I wouldn't
consider joining seg I'm not saying I
shouldn't it's never been invited
people don't invite me anywhere I'm just
an [__] and you know what so be it
I'm an [__] for democracy so I
figured it's the best kind of [__]
that I could be okay so let's get to
let's get to hoodiegate oh it's good
because I just showed you John fetterman
driving driving to
in solid to be in solid area with the
UAW so they can get their fair share of
the GDP
in this country that they help produce
it's them that that does the production
what do you think the labor is
let me show you um
uh let me show you uh this is this is
Senator Mark Wayne Mullen
Senator Mark Wayne
any from Oklahoma then this [__]
idiot from Oklahoma
and that where he's from I don't know
I'm not really sure
he's a republican so he might as well be
from Oklahoma right
no offense to Oklahoma really honestly
it shouldn't be that way unfortunately
Oklahoma is that way
it's kind of like these other red states
that are
packed in and diluted and controlled by
fascist
Theocratic fascist
but here he's bitching oh my God oh my
God
the worst thing in the world
is a hoodie
here's hoodie game listen to this
Schumer has now
his neanderers can be casual you don't
have to wear a suit and tie
do you think that's because he he wants
John fetterman to be able to wear all
those hoodies is that the reason what's
the reason
oh my god did you hear that did you hear
that they're suspending the rules that's
someone that hadn't dressed in a suit
and tie it's 2023 [__]
it's 20 23.
really honestly are we going to stand
around pretending that someone has to be
in a suit to do a job
especially like a United States Senator
do we re do we really I mean I'm not
saying that if if they choose to wear a
suit
I'm not saying that's a bad thing if you
want to wear a suit if you want to look
like that fine I'm I'm all for that
whatever you want to wear
and you notice that Republicans are
really into telling you
are really into telling you what you can
and can't wear
and why what you're wearing is the
reason why their religion hates you
right they're really into this
this is a thing that they do but listen
to Mark Wayne here
listen to his little victimhood
let's play it that serves a side of me
that's super excited about it because I
hate wearing a tie and I'd rather be in
blue jeans and pair of boots and a white
T-shirt
oh oh oh oh oh oh now I get it this is
more Lauren bobert type [__]
right this is more Lauren Bower type
[__] telling you what the [__] you can
and can't do with who and who you don't
love right that's consensual
and then she goes out to a crowded dark
theater
and someone's rubbing on her Hooters
honking on someone someone said that
yeah comment and and uh
on YouTube honking on her Hooters
honking on her Hooters and she's playing
pocket pool with him
on him for him I don't know I don't know
it's hard to tell exactly what's going
on
in that footage but there's definitely
something going on
um
anyways this is more of that type of
[__] hypocrisy okay this [__]
[__] Mark Wayne like yeah I would
nothing would please me more than dress
up in a pair of blue jeans a white
T-shirt and a pair of cowboy boots
but I'm gonna I'm gonna wear a suit
because because I hate liberals I'm
gonna wear this suit to own the libs
listen to this uh but the fact is that
you do dress for the job and we need to
be respectful of the position we hold uh
and I totally disagree with what he's
doing here but
yeah someone points out a really good
point on YouTube really good point this
is a really good point driving home uh
Michelle B says Jesus for flip-flops to
work
ah Michelle Jesus wore flip-flops to
work all right I don't need to go any
further after that that's it sorry you
guys I was gonna do some more commentary
but I can't
I can't after that comment
oh Jesus Jesus wore flip-flops to work
take that Mark Wayne his name is Mark
Wayne
Mark Wayne it's one word I'm not
[__] you
this is I'm I'm telling the truth look
at this
and unless Aaron's got it wrong his
[__] first name is two two words two
names Mark Wayne
doesn't that tell you all you need to
know about this [__] I know I
know a lot of people like Tony don't
make fun of people because of their
names why
why
you can change your [__] name just
like he can change his suit into a pair
of blue jeans with a white T-shirt
okay
he can change his [__] name he
doesn't have to he can change his name
to Mark or Wayne or Mark Wayne two words
come on
and I'm pretty sure you know I made fun
of a couple people's names and they got
mad because we had names of people in
the chat same name but I I highly doubt
there's a Mark Wayne in the chat and
even if there is a Mark Wayne in the
chat they probably hate that [__]
name and they don't even go by it they
either go by Mark or Wayne
just saying just saying just pointing it
out just trying to give you the [__]
truth here
I'm
oh boy Billy Bob yep you know um Jim Bob
you know what Jim Bob Duggar
remember Josh Josh Duggar I don't know I
think this first name [__] the two first
name things
foreign
I don't know I know but you know maybe I
could be wrong maybe I could be wrong
uh Mary Mary he says on YouTube I bet
there'll be a mark waiting in the chat
by tomorrow
there probably will be just a [__]
Tony I can't believe you said that about
that first name yeah
what do you want from me Mark what
haven't we had him on the show before
Mark went Senator yes
he was the one isn't he the [__] nah I
gotta go check it now isn't he the one
who says that
well [__] I forget hang on a second I've
gotta go look this up
I thought he was the one in a in a
senate hearing
that said some stupid [__] and we
because that's the only time I remember
this guy
on the show it's got it's got to be what
it was
oh man
well let's see
it was it was yes that's what it was
that's what it was
that's what it was he was talking about
he was talking about banning books
and
see yes and it was Bernie Sanders this
is it is this it
is that the one I think this is it I
think this is it
this is the same guy this was back in
March 29th
we were talking about this let's listen
to this this is the same guy this is
Senator Mark Wayne thank you well let me
respond Mr Senator did mention my name I
think
and I think you got an all-time record
here you made more misstatements in a
shorter period of time than I have ever
heard please correct well if I'm worth a
million excuse me no public excuse me
yeah go ahead all right Excuse me yes
sir if I'm worth eight million dollars
that's good news to me
I'm not aware of it that's a lie all
right number two third of public records
you're probably looking at some phony
right-wing into net stuff it ain't true
no uh you should read beyond that it is
not true public records no it is not
public right okay well you made this one
not a million on your public record you
make it all right excuse me I've got the
mic down number two
I've got it
you had your time okay all right you're
not telling the truth second of all you
got no evidence that I have ever said
that all CEOs I have never ever said
that
say it
furthermore what this hearing is about
is whether or not you talk about being
pro-union really what this hearing is
about is whether workers have the
constitutional right to form a union the
evidence is overwhelming not from me but
for the National Labor Relations Board
is the Time After Time After Time
despite what Mr Schultz is saying
Starbucks has broken the law and has
prevented workers from joining unions
to collectively bargain for decent wages
and benefits okay that wasn't the clip I
was looking for but that's a great clip
you want to know you want to know
something Bernie Sanders should go be
the moderator at Meet the Press
that's how that's how you [__] stop
all over their Lies by the way thank you
well let me respond by the way now I
think it was in the same exact hearing
um no it can be that this is uh this is
the one here it is this has got to be it
this is from Christopher Webb back on
June 2nd he was talking about a book
Mark Wayne was talking about a book in
this one let's listen I have a book yeah
and here in front of me called our skin
that has been endorsed by Nancy
do you want to burn it Mark Wayne is
that what you want to do you want to
burn it or do you want to read it like
like John Kennedy Rings genderqueer
about having dildos in his mouth and in
his you know but let's let's listen to
Mark Wayne here and let's listen if he
wants to burn this book or he wants to
read it uh and I'm gonna read exactly
what this book says you guys oh okay so
it's a horrible book it definitely
shouldn't have anyone hear this book but
we're gonna read it out loud in a public
Hearing in front of the cameras on
public record okay we should take you
seriously not you might find it
interesting a long time ago way before
you were born a group of white people
made up an idea called race yep that's
true that's true Mark Wayne it was a
long time before your dumb ass white
nationalist cuck
was born way before you were born you
cuck well let's go on that's the truth
okay let's keep going they sorted people
by skin color and said that white people
were better smarter prettier and they
deserved more than everybody else yep
that's the truth too I mean you don't
like it in that Elementary tone you know
that's not our [__] problem that the
truth has fed to you like you're a
three-year-old you need the truth like
you're a three-year-old but you know I I
upset that you're mad
this would be taught if we socialize our
Pre-K system this would be the Pre-K
system in the the okay the Pre-K system
is socialized you [__] idiot
it is socialized at every move these
people are dumb now Bernie Sanders is
going to walk all over him here but
there's one line in this that is
hilarious now watch watch this do you
disagree with that findings in the book
a thousand percent how about we teach
Jesus loves me
how about we teach Jesus because that's
religion dummy that's religion I don't
know if you know that but let's go on
how about how about this if teaching
Jesus loves loves the little children
the letters go red and yellow black and
white they're all precious in our sight
someone you know what you know what
you're right Mark Wayne what we should
do is teach the Jesus loves me and
the Islam version of that and the
Buddhist version of that right I mean we
teach one yeah we got to make them all
available that's why we don't do the
whole religion thing is because we do
one we got to do them all and you guys
would hate that you [__] bigotry
white Christian nationalists would hate
that oh my God you would hate that
if if Islam was being taught the
children you know oh my God you don't
say loser [__] minds
well let's keep going let's see if he
has a point here one point at me that
this being a truth that white people
developed race
that white people develop that that all
sudden that was our word that we
developed it's one of the reality is so
do you think this is could she answer
the question please because I don't want
reality I'm asking the question which
one is better that is exactly
okay he doesn't want reality right he
doesn't want reality he he wants he
wants his version of reality
and that's and that is the thing that's
the thing that's what put Mark Wayne on
the map here is he doesn't want reality
so it's no surprise that he thinks it's
just egregious that in 2023 that someone
wears a [__] hoodie but there is Mark
Wayne Mullen
he's a United States Senator and you
know what's funny about the he sits next
to Tommy turberville right
he sits next to Tommy tuberville in
these hearings the two clips I just
showed you is sitting next to Tommy two
branches the same Tommy tuberville is
who is demonizing women in the military
and demonizing their right to receive
health care and crossing state borders
and to receive that Health Care he's
demonizing the holding up military
promotions over it
putting our national security at risk
not only that he doesn't know that
there's two branches of government he
doesn't know that
I don't know if you know that but he
doesn't know that but he doesn't know
that all right enough of the Mark Wayne
[__] none of this [__] idiot all
right let's move on let's see here
um I want to show you speaking of
descent there's another fight that
everybody's gonna get blamed for too
damn it
and everything's not working just the
way I wanted to everything's kind of
freezing up here and we're gonna get
Gabe Sanchez on here in just a bit let
me see let me let me make sure if he's
I'm preparing for game are you coming on
in advance
I just want to make sure see if he is
okay
so we I think Gabe Sanchez might join us
for a minute or two before his show
starts and his show is going to start
here on YouTube what you'll be able to
do is just stay right here on YouTube
it feels like I'm freezing up again yeah
but it may not be frozen up on the live
feed all right here's Fox News Sunday
Karl Rove was on there
and uh Carl Rove
um is really [__] warning the
Republicans that a government shutdown
is not going to be good which is not
going to be and but I'll let him explain
why Republicans are [__]
it's funny coming from Karl Rove there's
another fight that everybody's gonna get
blamed for too another Hill headline
says this lawmakers prepare for shutdown
Blame Game Carl this never seems to go
well for anyone but it does generally
seem that Republicans get blamed for
these shutdowns well generally because
Republicans are responsible for the
shutdown
generally generally the Republicans are
responsible for shutdowns generally no
they always are the reason why
Republicans are always responsible for
shutdowns is because they don't know how
to govern
it's like a core tenement of their party
they're like ah man
oh man we don't know how to govern so we
won't do it we just won't govern that's
what we'll do and that's
why they're always blamed because they
always don't govern
and you're part of the problem Carl like
you you set this [__] into motion
one of the reasons why we have the
issues that we have let's let's listen
so yeah there's a reason why they get
blamed and and look the American people
demand that they're at someone someone's
correcting me tenant not tenement listen
if you want me to be a hillbilly you're
gonna have to
you're just gonna have to go with all
the hillbilly [__] that I see even
if it's not the right words or it's the
wrong words you're just gonna have to
live with it you're just gonna have to
know that
um
one of those I was one of those Hills
billies that knows all the words all
right
Thank you Pam for joining in and thank
you for correcting me I appreciate the
dissent especially on when I say [__]
wrong but it's probably not going to
help me I promise you
um I'm to set in my ways to be like this
let's keep going government try and run
itself in an appropriate fashion and the
fact that the biggest financial and
business Enterprise in the world the US
government can now pass a budget in time
and then ends up shutting itself down
over things that are on the margin I
mean we're talking about uh the
difference between this and that and uh
the Republicans are going to be shoot
themselves in the foot run in the run-up
to the 2024 election if they continue to
to think that shutdowns are a great way
to put themselves in front of the
American people but there's another
fight that everybody's gonna get again
car Rove making excuses and again this
is going to fall flat-footed because no
one in the Republican party has taken
um Karl Rove seriously in a long time
and the reason why is because he won't
go along with their [__] it right I
mean it's just a fact I've got a venmo
chat coming in here
um so let me let me get it up on the
screen it's it's from Rico Rico on
Discord
um ask the question
says when will the doj be announcing gun
charges against bobert lying on her
Firearms forms that's a good question
and how many children saw her lewd act
that's a good question too I mean these
are all good questions to ask these are
all good questions to ask but I mean
here's the thing is that if you think
that Republican um prosecutors like
Weiss
aren't charging Hunter Biden because
he's Hunter Biden
I don't know what I I mean the reason
why Hunter Biden is being charged with
this which
likely with the Supreme Court that we
have Hunter Biden's going to take this
to springboard and he's probably going
to win the argument that they shouldn't
be charging them with this just because
of how they interpret the Second
Amendment which is kind of ridiculous
but it is the way it is because people
like Hunter Biden and people like Lauren
bobert probably shouldn't just be able
to buy whatever firearm they want
if you're out there you know doing drugs
and doing [__] that isn't exactly on the
up and up rather you disagree with it or
not I mean I'm not saying that people
who do drugs can't be functioning
members of society but we probably
shouldn't be giving
people who do drugs on a regular basis
and who drink on a regular basis
Firearms she probably shouldn't be doing
it I don't know seems like it seems like
a pretty good policy to me most people
shouldn't have access to Firearms you
want to know the honest truth to any
Firearms but
when we're talking about weapons of war
we definitely or handguns we definitely
shouldn't be just handing them over to
people who who really on a frequent
basis do drugs and drink alcohol
this probably shouldn't happen and
people who do drugs and drink alcohol
probably should have this mindset that I
probably shouldn't have a firearm I
probably perhaps probably something I
shouldn't be doing it's just willy-nilly
carrying around a a pistol because I
think it makes me cool even though I'm
out getting drunk and high and all kinds
of crazy [__] right and how many
children saw her lewd act I have no idea
it's in the dark room right I mean it's
the hypocrisy of it all that really
pisses me off it's not really the
consensual grabbing that bothers me it
was consensual it was obviously
consensual and they're two adults you
know they were acting like [__]
teenagers but what are you gonna do they
kicked him out of the theater for it you
know
they didn't get anything out I don't
think I don't believe that the video
showed them getting anything out meaning
no nudity so I mean you know they're
grabbing each other through their
clothes and the theater kicked them out
for that and having them Flash and
vaping just a disturbance in general so
it's taken care of at that level but
again there's so many other [__]
reasons to be so pissed off at who
Lauren bobert is and why she why in the
hell is she a congressperson
in the first place
that that this this act in the theaters
should be low level but you know I'm
agreeing with you here maybe we should
start the question if Hunter Biden can
be charged if Hunter Biden can be
charged
maybe Lauren bobert can be charged as
well with lying on a a gun form what do
you think Gabe Sanchez you think she
lying on a gun form I don't know I think
she lies she lies a lot so it we
definitely know that she lies a lot it's
the possibility that she might have lied
on the gun form the very thing that she
attacks you know Hunter Biden for she
might and probably are you calling her a
hypocrite cause I feel like you're
saying that
oh okay pretty good she is one by the
way she is
she she is one of those she's one of
them Hypocrites you you say she is she
is so what are you going to talk about
the Trump interview today with
Christopher what are you going to talk
about no I'm not going to talk about
like [__] that [__] covered that enough
I'm gonna what are you talking about
today in yourself same old [__] I'm
gonna talk about I'm going to talk about
bobert yeah talk about the I'm gonna
bring up the interview that she did the
uh fake ass apology that she gave on
Friday so you're gonna go over this
bobert stuff I'm gonna go over Bob
I think I know him I'm gonna go over
Russell Brand whoa that wait wait wait
let's let's take this step by step
because I heard some stuff about the
South Dakota governor that she also
might like to go to Beetlejuice uh but
with Corey Lewandowski is that is that
the story yeah she likes to go to
Beetlejuice it's that she likes to juice
the beetle you know what I'm saying oh I
see I see you know now that I have you
on the screen I look so fuzzy you do and
and your color in the background looks
green it's no no that my TV is really
[__] up oh okay TV's actually I was
like oh you're trying new colors out all
right my lights my lights are [__] up
they're getting old man oh time to get
now I guess so I guess so anyways
any I just noticing how crisp you are
and how oh yeah yeah Carrie Lake type
filter I am
there was a moment I was not I was
almost not even gonna do one today even
though today is not normally uh alive
for me just because I'm going out of
town I'll miss uh Wednesday Thursday but
um I know I know it's because I'm
traveling maybe Thursday but you said
you weren't going to do it but
my my voice is a little my throat was a
little sore this morning oh my [__] but
did you go to Beetlejuice this weekend
nobody was juicing my beater this
weekend okay
[Applause]
yeah but no the reason is because I had
a I had a show last night I had a live
show here in L.A
um I have a monthly sketch show that I
have with the team I see well you you
had messaged me and said that you
weren't going to be doing your your
Sunday live after mine right so I didn't
throw to you yesterday and then I'm
throwing to you today which is kind of
you know awkward I'm trying to make up
for that you know right I know I know I
know right so here here's the thing
here's the thing everybody stay tuned
because you're gonna go directly to what
was that live with the guy with the last
name Sanchez right after this right
after this you don't have to go anywhere
if you're on Twitch or you don't touch
that dial as they say on red don't touch
that dial so um you're gonna go talk
about Lauren bobert you're gonna bring
it over
Lewandowski they definitely are juicing
the beetle oh yeah and and Russell Brand
you're gonna talk about him where he is
um accused of criminal rape and assault
I think yeah abuse
sexual assault rape I mean there's
allegations of grooming
um it's no wonder Andrew Tate type
person oh not only Andrew Tate it's
Andrew Tate Elon Musk uh you know our
our boy our boy Solomon yeah I've never
had his [__] Beetlejuice right and
then it pulls my finger what do all
these people have in common feels like
they have something in company yeah and
you know who the new one is I I haven't
watched a full clip yet is uh
is Alex Jones
oh what Alex Jones
listen listen if you're in a plane if
you're in if you're in a reality where
Alex Jones Andrew take Tucker Carlson
Elon Musk and Solomon are all are all
defending you you are on the wrong side
of Rihanna yeah if that is if that is
your uh defense or counsel that's like
look we're going to show you how good of
a person that Russell Brand is
ouch I mean it's almost it's almost it's
almost as strong of a support team as
Donald Trump when it comes to his
attorneys it's true it's true so you're
saying you're saying these people trying
to defend is is like Alina Hava trying
to explain to us why the presidential
records Act is is actually an events to
have yeah pretty pretty much yeah I mean
like you know and I'll talk about on the
show but you know the the thing I'll
leave you with is
whenever there's an allegation like this
against someone who you for the most
part is like yeah I could see that uh uh
if you have people who are defending you
like Elon Muslim oh interesting oh they
it's competition they want to come after
us if you have someone saying that you
could just be like you know what just
[__] throw your your hat in the ring
and say
you're guilty I'm guilty uh that's that
was totally
look I don't have a chance of defending
myself now so I'll just uh lock me up
it is well they should lock them up I
want to say one more thing before you
get off the air Mike Mike
um sent in a round for everyone so I
wanted you to know that oh we got we're
gonna do a shot here soon okay
um so well right now yeah around there
you go take it take a shot of one I
don't have a shot of not yet or later
well the go go go get your show ready
and then do the shot all right sounds
good all right we'll see we'll see you
soon on the other side my run all right
Gabe Sanchez everybody stick right here
on YouTube or twitch you're gonna go
right into what was that live with the
game the Sanchez as it were so don't
don't go anywhere if you're on the main
YouTube channel
or if you're on the twitch channel one
more time I want you guys to go follow
speaking of YouTube I want you to go
follow the library of democracy that's
your homework for today if you guys have
homework is go to YouTube and please do
me a huge favor and you're gonna want
this content at your fingertips as it
comes and as we post it over there on
the library of democracy your our
favorite local librarian is the
librarian at the librarian democracy
Allison the mighty librarian over there
and there's a few videos already there
for you to watch and to find a way to
engage I want to thank everyone for the
venmo chats today also all the shots
that have been rolling in it really does
help us keep going and you keep my
microphone on and I couldn't keep it on
without you and your support here and I
appreciate the 18 000 subscribers and
we're gonna get to 20 really soon and
just keep sharing those links keep
engaging in your democracy but engaging
here at the Tony Michaels podcast
don't go anywhere I'm telling you You're
Gonna Wanna stick around for Gabe
Sanchez's Monday this week his Monday
version
what was that live with Gabe Sanchez
same time same place tomorrow folks
right here the Johnny Michaels podcast
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon